[Music]
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
congratulations you've just been killed
by a mermaid
welcome to the afterlife i guess you're
probably wondering
how could i have avoided this there's
nothing more annoying than going for
your daily run
only to be interrupted by some random
mermaid who wants to drown you
luckily for you and myself today's video
is sponsored by raycon
vote is the number one anti-mermaid
mythical creature wireless earbuds on
the market
by me if you're in need of a slick pair
of wireless earbuds that are comfortable
affordable and have crisp audio quality
then stick around into the end to find
out more
i think we're all somewhat familiar with
mermaids by now
whether it's a beautiful woman with a
fishtail who majestically swims through
the ocean
or something far more seductive that
would drown you without a second thought
if you dared to venture too close
every region has its own stories
surrounding them
and some of them are quite dark and
twisted so join me today as we take a
look at mermaids and their rather messed
up history
the most common description of a mermaid
is that of an aquatic creature with the
head
and torso of a woman and the lower half
of a fish but depending where you are in
the world
that can vary one of the biggest
influences in the west regarding
mermaids comes from the
sirens of greek mythology who despite
often being confused and compared with
mermaids or in fact
more bird than fish we see the sirens in
two of greek mythology's most well-known
epic poems
the argonautica and the odyssey in both
of these they are fairly
similar to modern mermaids using their
enchanting voices to
lure sailors into a watery grave
which is where the term a siren's call
comes from
being enticed to go somewhere or do
something
that we know will end poorly something
i'm sure many of us can relate to
when the argonauts encountered the
sirens their musician
orpheus drowned out the siren song with
his own song
and as a result only one man jumped
overboard
when odysseus and his crew encountered
the sirens he instructed his men to fill
their ears with beeswax
in order to nullify the singing odysseus
himself however was
extremely intrigued that no man had ever
heard the siren
song and lived to tell the tale and so
he further instructed his crew to tie
him to the mast of his ship
no matter how much he begged and pleaded
with them to release him
they were to ignore him until they
passed safely by the sirens
authors after homer believed if a man
heard the siren song
and survived the sirens would have to
drown themselves in the sea
once we get closer to the hellenistic
period images of sirens shifted from
bird women to women with a fishtail
roman authors in particular such as
hygienist
and ovid heavily linked the sirens to
the ocean
ovid himself helped popularize the
origin story of sirens
according to him they were not always
half woman half
bird originally they were the nymphs and
handmaidens to the goddess persephone
in the versions of the story where
persephone was abducted by hades and
taken to the underworld
her mother demeter gave the handmaidens
wings so they could aid in the
search for her lost daughter hygienus on
the other hand saw this as
more of a curse demeter blamed the
handmaidens for her daughter's
disappearance
and so in anger she transformed them
into the sirens
the siren song although beautiful and
alluring also has a strong undertone of
sorrow
and even death continually calling out
to persephone
in the hopes she may one day return
before we move away from greek mythology
for those wondering if there was a
male equivalent merman did also exist
one example was a man who went by the
name of glaucus
a fisherman who discovered a magical
herb that would bring fish back to life
when consumed curious of its effects on
mortals he tried some for himself
this resulted in his legs becoming a
fishtail
and the overwhelming desire to live in
the sea
although he was now considered immortal
glorca struggled to come to
terms with his newfound gift that is
until the
other deities of the sea taught him its
secrets
and even the art of prophecy from then
on glaucus was known as someone who
would appear to those
lost at sea in order to guide them to
safety
one of his most noticeable appearances
is in the argonautica
where he appears to the argonauts and
informs them of what really happened to
heracles and the other missing men
helping to stop a full-blown mutiny from
the crew members who blamed
jason for the disappearance of heracles
the most well-known example of a merman
in greek mythology was
triton the son of poseidon and
amphitrite neither of his parents are
ever really described as merfolk because
they could live on both land
and sea triton however is described as
being
half man and half fish from the day he
was born
making him the stereotypical merman
for the most part he acted as his
father's messenger within the sea
which makes sense considering covering
the underworld
the earth the heavens and the sea may
have been a bit too much for hermes to
handle alone
similar to glaucus he also appeared to
the argonauts to aid them in the return
leg of their journey
however there are numerous images of
triton wrestling
and drowning heroes and other mortals
heracles wrestling triton is an image
you see
often in greek pottery the image of
merman became so
heavily associated with triton himself
that they were eventually just known as
tritons
or tritone the musical fishermen of the
ocean
moving to the eastern parts of the
mediterranean
and mesopotamia there are numerous
stories to examine
images of humans with fish tales can be
traced as far back as the first
babylonian empire
the mesopotamian goddess atargatis is
one of the first recorded stories of
mermaids
in this region she fell in love with a
human shepherd who sadly
drowned in a lake not being able to deal
with the pain of being apart from each
other
she threw herself in the lake in the
hopes that she would also drown
and reunite with her lover in the
afterlife
the gods however would not allow her to
die and so they made the ocean her new
home
they transformed her into a fish at
least her lower half
her torso would remain that of a woman
because her beauty could not be hidden
one thousand and one nights is also a
great texture read if middle eastern
ideas surrounding mermaids pique your
interest
there are numerous stories that feature
humans who are able to breathe and live
underwater these are described as sea
people or seabourn
now if there's one place we can rely on
for these stories to get
super weird in terms of appearance you
can always count on japan
here you have creatures known as ningya
which means human fish and i can promise
you
they are in no way seductive mermaids
the ninja are not part fish they are
mostly fish with their head being the
only part that resembles a human
they also had golden horns a red belly
and additional eyes around their torso
hunting and capturing these creatures
required a
rather large group as they were said to
be around
35 feet long so definitely more of a
monster than mermaid in slavic folklore
there are creatures known
as the rusalika female spirits had dwell
in lakes and rivers
luring young men to their death with the
sound of their voices
these are said to be the spirits of
young women who dined from drowning
because of an unhappy marriage
this can be a suicide due to being
abused and harassed
or even jilted by a lover it can also be
because they may have been murdered by
said lover an example often used would
be an unwanted child
resulting in them being drowned to hide
the pregnancy
the spirit is then cursed to spend their
remaining time as a resalica
seeking vengeance before the 19th
century
the rosalica were not always considered
the evil
they were associated with fertility
during the spring they would emerge from
the water
and walk among fields in doing so they
transferred a portion of their own
essence which would seep into crops and
allow them to be nurtured
during the 19th century they were
perceived as chaotic
and unclean spirits it was common to
hear stories of young women dying by
lakes and rivers becoming
rusalka when young men approached the
riverbed
they would be mesmerized by the singing
and when they were close enough the
rusalika would entangle them in their
long
vibrant hair wrap their feet around them
and drag them below the water as odd as
it may sound
in countries such as poland they prefer
to tickle their victims to death
as opposed to drowning them which sounds
equally as horrifying
they can also alter their appearance to
suit the desires of their victim
from afar they appear as beautiful women
but when up close their hair colour
changes to a
mouldy green and their face distorts
showing their true nature they were not
however always considered malevolent or
evil spirits for the sake of being evil
much like a poltergeist if their death
was in some way avenged
then their spirit would be allowed to
rest
they may not be half woman half fish but
they do share several similarities with
mermaids
you have the colorful vibrant hair the
idea of beauty
and most rusalika had to remain
partially submerged in the water
making trips to land not very common
the rasalika was a symbol of immense
beauty
but also one that was extremely feared
and respected
mermaids were also mentioned in britain
and ireland
during the medieval period coming across
a mermaid at sea was considered a bad
omen in some cases mermaids would
foretell troublesome weather
or some kind of disaster other times the
mermaids themselves would cause ill
fortune
the ballad of sir patrick spenz talks
about
a rather cryptic mermaid she would tell
sailors and ships at sea that they would
never see land again
and other times she would lie to them
and tell them that they were near the
shore
those who were not lost at sea could
tell that they were nowhere near land
this just meant their vessel was fated
to crash into rocks
there were also cautionary tales
involving mermaids drowning people in
rivers and lakes if they came too
close on rare occasions some of these
stories were more
positive such as mermaids helping those
who were drowning
and even teaching them medicines and
cures that were found in nature
some other mermaids from around the
world worthy of a mention
include the european melucina
the mother of water spirits native to
central africa and the chinese shark
people
stories of mermaids have existed for
thousands of years
all over the world and there is no
shortage of them in modern fiction
either
when you have stories and legends that
are universally told
and stand the test of time it's normally
because there is something there we can
relate to
or reflect upon something that intrigues
but also still leaves an
element of mystery when it comes to
mermaids it's not hard to see
why people enjoy them in stories their
tragic past
and the duality between beautiful and
deadly above the water there is a calm
beautiful and elegant exterior which
plays on your humanity and draws you in
below it's mysterious cold dark and
unforgiving
a pretty accurate description of how we
used to and
even sometimes today still view the
ocean
sailing the seas thousands and even
hundreds of years ago was much more
perilous than it is today
mermaids are just one of a long list of
creatures created to try and explain
these stories
they also serve as a reminder that
appearances
can be somewhat deceiving
as we mentioned earlier today's video
has been made possible by
raycon finding a good pair of wireless
earbuds can be
very expensive but not with raycon
they offer premium wireless earbuds in
all sorts of colors and designs
at a fraction of the price you'd expect
to pay
at raicon they prioritize the customer
experience
which is why they offer a 45-day return
policy
raycon earbuds give you six hours of
playtime and are extremely comfortable
making wearing them for long periods of
time a joy
and not a nuisance their seamless
bluetooth pairing means you can step
away from your screen
whether it's to go do some chores or
just lay down and still enjoy whatever
you were listening to
if you're someone who's ever trying to
exercise with regular earbuds you'll
know what a nightmare it can be
the first time i went for a run using my
raikon earbuds i was expecting to be
running down the street trying to find
where i had lost them
but they didn't budge in fact you can
jump around to your heart's content
and because they fit so snugly they
won't move
and this goes for all sorts of exercise
if that sounds good
you can get a 15 percent discount by
visiting
slash byracon.com that's byrakon.com
mythology or you can use the link in the
description
go and check out raycon today as it
really helps support the channel
as always i've been your host
mythology and fiction explained
reminding you to maybe stay away from
the fish women
[Music]
[Music]
you